you
[Music]
okay with that I went to the introduced
Christian Grauman who is a professor at
the department of computer science at
the University of Texas at Austin
she's also over the last at most public
two years now or year and a half
been a scientist research scientist at
Facebook AI research and so Kristen does
III think inspiring research computer
vision with the machine learning focus
of course focusing on recognition and
search tasks before joining UT Austin in
2007 she did her PhD work at MIT I think
she was overlapping with Ashish there
and so I remember she was my first
exposure to Christian actually was where
she got interested in some of the active
learning and act and and active evidence
gathering work that Ashish and I were
doing and we actually saw her applying
this with Trevor Darrell in terms of
visual tasks it was very exciting for us
to see something picking that up and
taking it forward mm-hmm and we're
continuing here Christian is an AI
Tripoli fellow triple AI fellow Sloan
fellow and we said you know in an NSF
Career Award ONR ywp young investigators
program I guess it is we say yep PKS
pammi young researcher award it was
really nice to see her in 2013 be
selected to give the itch computers and
thought award which is like the kind of
leading recognition for a young computer
scientist in AI and more centrally she's
been has had many people that's paper
awards over time won the 2017 Helmholtz
prize for test of time award and I have
to say that he never singling out any
researcher but I just love following
questions really creative work and the
diversity of her of her fun explorations
and vision in multimodal inference and
it's always great catching
with her and her latest thinking so um
I'll just turn the mic over to Christy
thanks Christy here okay okay hi
everybody thanks Eric for the intro
great to see you all here I'm going to
talk about some of our recent work and
first-person vision or egocentric vision
and this talk is meant to give a an
array of ideas that were exploring along
the seam and so I've kind of kept it at
the the high level in some sense for
most parts but I'm happy to go into
detail through your questions or offline
about any given part depending on
interest okay so let me jump right in so
I'll set the stage in terms of the big
picture that this room people in this
room probably know well which is in
computer vision we've had tremendous
success in the last 10 years you know
five to eight years where the right
ingredients came together at the right
scale
the ones you see here to allow us to do
object naming scene naming even activity
naming and images and videos and so this
combination a big labeled crowdsource
data sets with deeper and deeper
networks and GPUs let us tackle as a
field the visual recognition tasks quite
well and this was most famously
evidenced by this great and quick drop
in error on what's known as the image
benchmark challenge this is a challenge
where you're given an image you need to
say which of a thousand object
categories is present
okay so heavily supervised methods
training at a very large scale can do
this quite well and by some measures
with an asterisk in there as well as
people can do this particular task and
this is huge this has been allowing us
as a field to look at bigger and bigger
problems now I want to make sure that we
look at what a challenge like imagenet
or other related challenges over the
years do in terms of the data ok so how
are these systems learn again they're
learned from images labeled by people so
that we can learn discriminant models to
find these things again a new content
now these benchmarks are really powerful
they've pushed the success they also
have certain properties that we don't
always notice explicitly so let's call
attention to them here
two things one
there's what I call disembodied so these
are observations photos from the web
that were downloaded and made their way
into these training sets teaching all
our algorithms that are now at that
moment outside of the physical context
of a particular event right so they're
out of the physical context the spatial
or temporal context of when that
happened that's even true if it's a
video okay it's just a snippet of the
world then the second thing is they're
well curated these are pictures or
videos that are taken by people and
people are pretty smart about knowing
where to look what moment to take that
picture how to frame it that those
facets are a little bit dangerous too
because they are putting in some
intelligence to the task before the
machine even I have sent into the
picture okay so if you can track this
kind of world with the first-person
perceptual experience I hope right away
you can see there's a big contrast right
so here I'm showing you a first-person
video captured from a head mounted
camera worn by a person doing some daily
life activity and you can see that in
this kind of visual observation first of
all it's not just the curated moment
it's based in time it's every moment
right it's the relevant things it's the
irrelevant things it just keeps going
it's an ongoing very long stream
furthermore this is an egocentric
perception or perceptual experience that
it's very much linked to the intentions
and goals of the person wearing the
camera okay we're not just seeing a
crafted moment or a photo we're seeing
things that are a function of what they
want to do in the world and furthermore
they're changing the world as they do it
you know picking up things opening doors
etc finally this is a multi-sensory
experience I'm not playing audio now I
don't have touch sensors to show you
here but we know that of course this
egocentric world that we experience that
our robots should experience is going to
be multi-sensory not just visual so
we're looking closely at this contrast
and in my group and other groups in the
field we're trying to look to move from
this status quo of internet photo
learning towards this world where we
have agents systems that can learn in
the context of their own motion in
action their interaction with the
environment and also multi-sensory and
observations and I put the child there
just think helping us trigger that
thought of you know we can
learn outside of heavy supervision we
know we do this ourselves where just by
being in the world and experiencing in
our first-person way we gain supervisory
signals such as as I'll say in a minute
being able to anticipate how things will
change when we do different things and
then this shift will also allow us to
tie to applications and even be
motivated by applications in augmented
reality and robotics okay so what I'm
going to show you then are ways we're
trying to move towards first-person
perception thinking about so called
embodied perception and in particular
I'm going to focus on methods were
developing that allow systems to learn
through anticipating the effects of
their own actions okay and there's three
parts I want to share I'm gonna focus
more than two-thirds of the remainder of
this talk on the audiovisual part and
I'll show you two things one
multi-sensory audio-visual learning for
feature learning so representation
learning from both streams okay and I'll
talk about spatial audio there and then
I'll build on this to talk about
navigation policies so we want agents
that move and learn in the world they
need to steer their own movement how are
they going to do it intelligently from
this multimodal stream and then the last
final part of the talk I'll talk a bit
about interaction so this is where we
care about looking at the world not as
objects to name but objects that have
the ability to afford different actions
and we the agent needs to be able to
look at them in video and expect what
those actions might be okay so three
parts let's go right now into this first
and here we get our moment of then two I
want you to imagine yourself in this
forest
okay now this video showed for this
human videographer how there is a very
close link between what is seen and what
is heard and in particular the spatial
facets of what is heard right so there
was a bird in the tree they were kind of
steering the camera towards the bird to
try and get a closer look and had you
been listening to this audio track with
headphones in fact this would be very
rich spacial an immersive experience
about feeling as if you're there and
sensing the spatial location of that
object now why can we do this why do we
have as first-person agents have spatial
sensing in our sound well we have two
ears as we experience binaural sound
where the position of us sounds worse in
the world reaches our two ears
differently such that we can then learn
effects like the different time delay of
the signal reaching the left ear versus
the right ear or the level differences
the intensity of the sound being
stronger in the nearer ear damped more
dampened in the farther ear or even the
affects of our outer ear shape which
they will affect exactly how we receive
these reflections of sound so we can
interpret this with our two ears okay so
we embodied agents do this however if
you look at an off-the-shelf method
that's that's processing single channel
audio or monorail audio these special
spatial effects have been collapsed and
it's flat right there's no spatial
signal it's just the sounds without
their physical context great so the what
we'd like to be able to do is have our
algorithms sensing spatial sound or even
producing it and so the task I want to
present us from our work now is the task
of being able to lift from monaural
single channel audio to binaural audio
such that it has the right spatial
properties for a human listener or if we
like a robot listener so how are we
going to do this I just said we've
collapsed everything in mono roll audio
well spatial information while invisible
here is very visible here and so what
we're going to do is look at these
simultaneous tracks the audio and visual
streams and learn this associate
so that we can watch this video here the
flat audio and in anticipate hallucinate
or lift to this binaural sound so in
other words input is mono audio and
video output is the appropriate binaural
counterpart for the audio so for before
I say a little bit more about how we do
it why do we want to infer binaural
sound so I was motivating in terms of
well in bodies agents they have spatial
sensing we want to get this but even
before that we know that if we can
achieve this for an arbitrary monaural
audio signal with video we can upgrade
the audio experience for human listener
so we could make a video immersive as if
you were there experiencing the sound
with your two years but furthermore for
our systems I'll show you in a minute
how this will help us be able to learn
representations that improve tasks for
audio visual processing for example
audio source separation where knowing
where things are in the world and then
hearing the sounds accordingly allows
you to disentangle which source is
making which sound alright so back to
this task then here's how we set it up
during training we have video in which
we know the binaural sound okay so this
is a requirement it's unlabeled video
humans haven't done anything to it but
it has a binaural sound with it from
that video we can collapse to the mono
audio and look at the spectrogram the
sounds frequencies over time captured by
this matrix for a given video clip then
on the bottom here we have the visuals
stream these are just just renderings to
hint at the objects that might be
important it's just going to be a raw
video chunk over time and then we'll
train a convolutional neural network
that can take these inputs and lift to
the binaural sound so during training I
know I have a law that says we need to
be able to reproduce these from just
this and this and we can train this
network to do this extraction which will
allow it to automatically clue in on the
visual pieces and their spatial relative
positions - to do the proper lifting and
then at test time we have only the mono
and we can lift it okay and keep in mind
this camera
be moving the objects in the world can
be moving what will be producing the
binaural sound for is the optical
relative to the optical center of the
camera whatever ever it was so to do
this we did want to collect data so that
we could train with nice fine or elles
sound and so to do to do that we just
made this rig with off-the-shelf
components so you have a 3d i/o binaural
microphone it's two microphones in these
ears and the ear shape is not just for
looks okay it's also it's really meant
to capture the sound for an average
human head capturing those effects of
the outer ear as well so their spacing
is like average at average human head
spaced then the eyes on top of there is
a GoPro camera and these are together so
again wherever it moves this is the ego
or first-person agent capturing the
sound and the sight then we did our
capture in a music room
so we had this music room at Facebook
with dozen instruments laying around
volunteers came in and different
combinations play them and now we have a
set of different sound sources with
variety of spatial locations okay so now
I want to show you and let you hear some
results the thing is you got to hear
this with headphones okay the whole
point is you're creating spatial sounds
you need those left and right waveforms
to go to your left and right ears I
can't do it in this room but I can show
you what's being produced in if it
interests you please check out the video
results online with headphones so what
we're gonna look at as an employee video
on top input mono audio here and then
what we're we're inferring for the
binaural streams and the ground shoots
on the bottom okay so let's listen to
this one
okay so like I said you can see this
like what you're wanting to see is that
these are the same you'll notice they're
subtly different left and right years
because of the subtle differences in how
we receive those sounds now to give you
a sense a bit more about how correct you
know and just see how we evaluate how
correct these are aside from just
looking at this ground truth Delta with
our prediction what we did is human
subject studies where we would not show
them the video okay so we'd hide the
video but we'd play the inferred audio
okay so imagine you hadn't seen that
video before but I play you the binaural
sound that the system produced then
we're gonna ask you a question like
where was the drumset okay so you know
listener is just hearing it oops and
then they need to point to where those
things were so in this example okay we
saw that then people would point say
over here for the drum and over here for
the piano without yet seeing the video
and in fact when we do this if you hear
the true binaural sound then when we
actually captured 80 percent of the time
people are correct and then 62 percent
of the time we're correct and the
nearest baseline is correct about 38% of
the time so you might say well I can't
they point to it and when I is it only
80 percent of the time with the true
binaural well there's different reasons
one reason can be that we actually do
experience audio specific to our own
heads and what we've learned is an
average human head our heads varying in
size you really need a what's called a
head related transfer function to
precisely interpret that audio for your
very head and ears that might explain
some portion of that that loss for the
ground truth all right so we're doing
this with instruments as I just showed
you but also other kinds of video and so
the data set we captured up there fair
play is the one but then we have a few
YouTube datasets that consists of 360
videos together with and a sonic audio
that is converted to binaural and these
contain things like tourist video sports
people talking kind of video
descriptions like how to cook something
in some kitchen and so on so these are
more
different and content and these are more
precise than the binaural capture so
across those datasets the fair play and
then the three YouTube ones I'm showing
you quantitatively than how well we're
doing and these are metrics saying
basically how correct are those
waveforms versus the ground truth
measured in two different ways
ours is the one on the bottom and you
can see this is an encouraging result
the kind of baselines we looked at
things like mono mono well if you just
copy them on or off stream twice this is
not crazy they're not that you know the
differences are subtle what if you
flipped the visual input that should
hurt because you're putting the objects
in the wrong place with respect to where
the sound should be and it does hurt
what if you just had the audio not the
visual and then ambisonics the system
competing and concurrent work for doing
this for ambisonics audio okay so these
are encouraging results um the other
part that we've been looking at I said
was not just to improve things for you
and I to listen to but for our systems
yes question the numbers again sure this
is this is a loss so lower is better
yeah it's an error that's right what is
it it's just the l2 error of the
Reconstruction era was it yeah right so
the I'm the error of the clean air on
the waveforms and then on the envelope
of those waveforms yes any question on
the human test you said that nearest
baseline did 32 percent because 38 yeah
okay so my 30 so 38 it seems like almost
if you switch the channels wouldn't you
then get 62 percent like yours or like
if it's if it's just left right I'm
going to two sides I'm just wondering do
they have the channels flip somehow in
the baseline or how does that end up
being right well there's different ways
you can make errors and one could be
putting things you know you could have
if the only way there that flipping them
is not the only way to make an error I'm
you can imagine this any kind of offset
within even a single channel could be
wrong I mean we're we're predicting the
the Delta from between the two and then
adding from one to the other so you
could be wrong in the direction but you
could also be wrong even even the
magnitude or the phase of the sounds
that you're producing
for like the baseline algorithm so like
if the baseline algorithm predicts that
can predict any of our the methods can
predict can be wrong not just in
swapping the ears yeah but it's an
interesting suggestion to you could
reinforce each baseline make sure that
if you had somehow they're not just left
to right reversed the vision the select
visual baseline does this only on the
the visual input side but not on the
output side take into account the
variations because of 3d it fall so I
would you network account for that yeah
so say depth was part of the input yeah
yeah networks nowadays do predict depth
from a single image right so if
instrument players are a different depth
in an auditorium yes the songs would be
different yeah absolutely and I you know
in data I'll show you in just a moment
will have the depth as part of the
sensing and so we can even use that
directly but I think you know an
empirical question would be do you need
to do the inference of depth from the
RGB will it help you along the way I bet
it would actually or here we're just
forcing it to learn directly from the
RGB and then certainly when as I said
when we have depth at the input level
this is an important thing to link to
the audio yeah for sure yes I just have
a related question right so you were
actually units you always used visual
input right and is it obvious human
produced sounds that so is it just a
algorithm matching on to the humans to
try and infer the depth or the distance
between two instruments in some sense oh
do you mean like it's all the sound
making happening from people not all so
the these kind of videos for example
this one has only a car that's probably
the major sound maker others do have
people so they're either as music and
there's people but then there's things
like skateboards rolling by which does
have a person attached to maybe there's
cars going by so it's a mix it's a bit
of a mix yeah but people in instruments
are dominant sound makers I think in
this data and vehicles so so I mentioned
them that kind of last thing I wanted to
show you on this piece was using this
for future learning so I'm just gonna
give it more of a
a result here so what we've done is take
this mono to binaural feature that's
been learned and then use this as an
encoding for the video and now perform
separation so we're doing audio source
separation the right answer is to come
back with a soundtrack for every sound
maker and what we can say what we can
show is that using what we call this two
and a half D visual sound representation
we can do a cleaner audio separation so
again more of a teaser here I'll show
you the original video and then what
we're getting for the separated sounds
here's the original here's the daug
separators and the violin
okay so you can hear that disentangling
happening it's not perfect but you can
hear how you start to separate and focus
your attention on one sound or the other
and the intuition why that's two and a
half G you helped is because doing this
properly you know think of the visual
the visual cocktail party problem as you
steer your attention spatially you can
linked that to how to steer it in the
audio signal as well and that's what
this encoding can help you do yes
sources how many did you try right yeah
so the datasets we've done the audio
source separation with there's not a
limit on the number of sources but
typical number in these natural videos
is two to three the ones where there's
more for example a big band and ensemble
it's harder and the methods do worse
yeah another place that's very
challenging still for these methods or
related methods doing separation
literature is a multiplicity than
objects so if you have a string of
people all playing violin or even just
two people playing guitar even even
sometimes two people speaking then you
know the frequencies are similar of
these sound makers and there's not much
harder to separate that said this is
where the attention to the subtle
motions of the different emitting sound
makers can help do the separation better
than if you didn't have the visual at
all yes so for this separation how many
moments do you have you have maybe you
have to merriments one on the next year
one on the right here ah the input is
mono okay so it's just what does one
okay do you think does just hello which
two moments will make this basket yes
yes we have them for sure I mean if you
kind of think of what we've just done is
to learn that lifting to to give you
that experience of multi-channel without
having measured multi-channel and the
motivation is that arbitrary video we
look at won't have multi-channel let
alone binaural tobin RL sound yeah but
more microphones the butter certainly
for this task we just don't always have
them or assume them so not me now talk
about navigation and I'd said at the
beginning we're talking about embodied
visual learning and this includes
multi-sensory and now I'm gonna show you
how it can bring together this
multi-sensory and spatial sound
standing with an agent that has to move
its own camera okay and this is brand
new work that I'm excited to show you so
firstly a little more context so in
computer vision there's increased
interest lately in looking at visual
navigation problems in novel unmapped
environments so this is not an
environment where you've gone in and
scanned it you've done slam it's all
mapped this is a new environment you
walk in your first view from the
egocentric agent is just one snapshot
and now you're going to view this over
time as you move so RGB from egocentric
point of view or RGB and depth and then
you can be given a task that's
navigation based like where's the
telephone or here's a picture of a
telephone can you find it okay there's a
lot of exciting work going on in this
space and really what's new coming from
the computer vision side is to do this
not purely in a geometric way so to
learn semantic priors essentially about
how world's indoor environments are laid
out such that the at the time of
encountering the new environment it's
not limited to just measuring it it's
also able to infer semantic context and
expect certain things when we turn
different ways so what I'm showing you
here is an egocentric point of view over
time of an agent that's exploring the
environment and at the same time
building up A to D occupancy map here
from the egocentric it's egocentric at
every moment about where things are and
where are navigable areas now what's new
again in this body of work that people
are exploring is to do this not purely
based on slam but to do it in a way that
we capture memories of spatial context
just like what have I seen where and
what am I likely to see saying when I
turn this corner and you can imagine how
this helps an agent if it has that
context to turn the corner when it's
likely to give new info or vice versa or
to go straight to where the telephone is
expected given the kind of rooms at
scene so this is all visual navigation
and novel unmapped environments what
we've been doing most recently is to
tackle this problem from a multi-modal
and body perspective so audio in pretty
good audio visual navigation why is
audio gonna help our agents navigate
well this is quite intuitive so here
I'll give you a few examples where sound
informs the navigating agent one if the
target of your
navigation is a sound emitting source
that's the one we're studying most
closely so the phone's ringing somewhere
in the house you need to go find it
how's the agent go navigate to it but
also other things like safety so you
know the dogs barking somewhere there's
some sound and that would indicate to an
agent places that should or shouldn't be
explored or navigated next semantics so
the agents down here but it here's water
running up to the top right which might
suggest what kind of room could be there
or could not be there and finally
materials so sound that we receive is a
function of both the physical geometry
of the space as well as the materials in
the space so imagine you know walking
across the marble floor versus walking
across a barely plush carpet you hear it
differently and so having a model even
during navigation that understands this
we'll have an expectation about
materials that are going to be
encountered okay so let me then show you
what we're doing more specifically we're
looking at that target based audio
navigation of the audio visual
navigation problem the agent is placed
into a novel unmapped environment we'll
only get its egocentric view plus or
minus depth RGB plus or minus death and
now it has to go navigate to that sound
source and here when I'm rendering on
this picture is a top-down view of some
3d environment with the pressure field
for the sound rendered in it and I'm
doing this so you can get a little hint
of why this could be so valuable for a
navigating agent even without giving it
a pointer to where that target is the
sound itself is revealing the general
direction of the target and furthermore
sort of some intermediate goals that the
agent might learn to approach because
here's if you can't tell these are
doorways here these are walls so if it
goes this way straight towards the sound
it'll slam into this wall but if it goes
to where the sounds bleeding out it'll
go very quickly to where it can actually
navigate towards the sound yes in the
experiments I'll show yes but for the
environment and platform we've created
not limited to it so you could add
together some multiple sources in
different places so how is this
different than
a setup where you have the ability to
navigate visually or whatever and simply
going in the path where you don't put
the Sun is increasing yeah this is this
is a good baseline right so so we could
what I'm about to show you in the model
we'll learn this but so it in principle
can be richer than solely an intensity
gradient of the sound to include things
like the materials major obstacles that
will you know we need to use the both
together right if I just follow the
intensity of the sound and not don't pay
attention to visual as the results will
show then for example I'll run into the
couch and now I've got to go around it
but if I saw it together with the sound
I don't need to remember these and
simply under use the frequency response
that guide you to those yes so in a
sense we're doing this and this is new
but we're doing it not by hand coding
neither are we hand coding you know that
we should pay attention intensity it's
gonna learn this from the audio
spectrograms directly yeah so let's say
a little bit more about we're doing here
so first we needed to create the
platform to do this kind of navigation
so in computer vision as some of you
already know we're getting a lot of
mileage and interesting problems out of
working in very realistic 3d
environments so before the robot at
least training in simulation and so
these are real-world scan meshes of 3d
environments that's so far I've been
purely visual and what we're doing is
starting to add the audio to them so
here we took the replica environments
which is a public repository from
Facebook of different 3d environments
like the one you see here this is an
apartment the apartment exists at
Facebook and now it's been scanned very
high-resolution very realistic and you
could render a picture from any
direction you wanted putting your agent
through this world and 3d and now we're
adding this sound so what that means is
we have a room impulse response station
that here a grid of locations a grid a
discrete grid only for for size reasons
we're gonna store the room impulse
response at each of these pairings of
source and receiver so in other words
you know given the data we've generated
here how
to render the appropriate sound to meet
the ears of your binaural agent when
it's at a given position and the sound
source is at some other given position
so if sound source were here for example
in my agent were at any of these black
dots we can render the appropriate to
spectrograms for the left and right year
for how they'll receive the sound when
standing at that position and it when
standing at one of four orientations so
this where we're trying to rate and
impact we pre computed it so now we can
rent pull these up on the fly for any
given position yeah accounting for
materials yeah so there's so you take
the 3d mesh and then these meshes like
others in Madhupur have semantic
segmentation saying what main objects
are everywhere and then we can map those
objects to materials that are then used
for the sound rendering yeah so sound
writing or itself is like a ray tracing
on the audio where you're you're
bouncing around these Ray's to then
collect the sound you'll receive to form
these room impulse responses and now you
can go involve with an arbitrary
waveform so you can make the phone ring
you can make the dog bark whichever
waveform you want to hear convolve with
this room impulse response you'll
receive that sound okay so this kind of
first step this hadn't been done before
we made this rendering possible for
these replica environments and now we
tackle this audio-visual navigation task
so I said we have an audio emitting goal
like the phone ringing and I'm gonna
play for you now a video to give you a
sense of what this means for our agents
so the left will be the RGB egocentric
view that's what the agent sees the
center is a top-down map of the
environment but remember the agent
doesn't have it yet it's just placed in
the new environment hasn't pre-mapped it
but will see it start to map it and put
start marking things in light gray as
they become known as far as occupancy
non occupancy for the agent and on the
right this is just a full rendering
top-down of the environment that this
this map corresponds to okay so let's
just listen to this again you got to do
it with headphones to hear the spatial
sound but you'll at least in here that
intensity in my video I mean the
intensity of the audio hopefully it's
intense in other ways too but mainly
intense and the changing audio here we
go
okay phone's ringing agents this spiral
starting to move out of that room it's
getting louder
starting to map sit that way no we could
explore over here but sounds coming more
this way getting louder beyond our left
side enter the room and this is very
good so this is the task that the agents
are solving so how we set up their
solution is through kind of a baseline
now approach or architecture for a
reinforcement learning agent that it's
going to take these multi sensor
observations and learn a policy for how
to navigate so where the action space is
moving in any direction or stopping and
then it'll be rewarded for being able to
navigate quickly to the right target so
the inputs on the left hand side are the
vision so RGB and depth and we try
ablations of how much either of those
matter the audio again spectrograms for
the left and right year the binaural
sound which is received from the
simulations I just mentioned and then
optionally GPS so in the world of visual
navigation people have been relying very
heavily on GPS in these indoor
environments in fact the norm is to
assume it's perfect and it always points
you straight to the goal so you enter in
the environment and there's a Delta X
Delta Y that says the goal is there
still non-trivial to get there because
you have to navigate actual obstacles
but it's a constant dense signal to
today's agents to say where the goal is
and I'll come back to that in a minute
okay so then these are the inputs the
observations and then we have this
reinforcement learning loop where here
we're using a simple model recurrent
model where we'll be sampling the
actions and then moving around in the
environment and then getting these new
observations and again the reward is if
we navigate efficiently to the target so
it's kind of a first approach to bring
in this audio now that we have it in
order to solve the audio based
navigation task
that you can check sure that they
reinforce but learning the procedure
with its when its Explorer is actually
learning something about given where you
are where to move that to actually
better listen so that you can better
move in the future based on change in
signal up the audio right implicitly
yeah because it's a very rich notion of
saying to gather information get to
gather evidence given where I am and
given my current conception of structure
and that patient path and location under
uncertainty where I moved not to get too
thick not to get closer but right so
better listen yeah yeah and there's
scope for that and you know first of all
the more multi-room the environment is
the more important that is if I'm just
in one in a room like this there's gonna
be less of the need for it but the more
your an apartment it has an upstairs and
a downstairs then you're it's less
myopic decision-making is needed this
model you know is a first stab and so
what we're doing we're even more
recently is making a map based memory
here that'll be even richer for encoding
this kind of long-term aggregation of
what I've heard where such that like you
said you could plan to not just observe
and get closer to the target but get to
the place that it'll hear better you
know maybe the agent was you know
standing behind the counter and then it
realizes well first thing I need to do
is get away from this out of beside this
counter so that I hear you know a more
open sound I just made up that sort of
close example though we're talking about
so is it just sparse for success or it's
done so you get a big reward if you when
you hit the target and say stop and you
get small rewards positive and negative
as you're moving closer closer
further deviating from the geodesic path
to the target yeah and as far a little
bit visualization about what's hot
what's it learning so kind of back to
your original question you know about
kill me and can we provide intensity and
follow this gradient for example it is
picking these out of the the raw
spectrums and learning them jointly with
the audio so what I'm showing you here
are T's new pots for the distance to the
goal on the left the angle to go on the
right for the audio
features we've learned okay so spectra
hands came in but then there's some
layers there that are learning to encode
it and here if we product all the way
down to two dimensions is how those lay
out and on the left on and right I'm
color coding with respect to these two
things so in other words you can see
that these points are clustering
together by color which means that
similar observations are at similar
distances to the goal which is good it
means it's starting to interpret the
sound that it receives as a measure of
how far it is from the goal and on the
right a little less so but there is some
signal of orientation that the agents
picked up from its learning coding to
say whether the goal is say to my left
or my right is coded here from blue to
red so just to say these features that
are learning are picking up on the
things we would expect to be necessary
to navigate well so now let me show you
some navigation results and I might
compare to what's called a point goal
agent so point goal is what I said
earlier where the norm today that people
are tackling very closely is where the
agent sees but it also always gets this
dense signal about the pointer to the
target it's a Euclidean pointer in you
know the not the shortest path geodesic
Li but just a pointer to the
displacement vector to the target and
here in this particular episode of
navigation what happened was the ground
truth shortest path from the starting
position to the goal is here in pink the
agents path in this case failed for this
baseline it's only can see and it has
the GPS and it ended up kind of bumping
into walls you know what's happening
here is that there's this strong GPS
displacement and pressure to move
towards this guy from here but you know
there's a wall here so that's the wrong
way to and ultimately go you need to
exit the room here or originally here
and come down to the goal so it can be
misleading and inefficient for the
navigation and so in this case point go
over you know the whole test set of
doing these kind of episodes whether
using no vision whether using RGB or
depth is getting these levels of what's
called SPL success rate normalized by
path length okay so now the key place
where the audio helps so now let's
I keep the GPS fine but I also have the
audio now the same environment we're
navigating from this starting position
again again pink is the shortest path
and our agent took this not shortest but
rather relatively short path in the blue
to get down to the goal and it succeeded
in this case and so you can see how the
audio to remember my pressure field
sketch like handful of slides before
where there was the sound bleeding out
of the doorways this is where it's using
that effect right it's learned that
given the GPS pointer is pointing that
way fine but there's sound indicating
that first we need to exit that door I
enter a new door and come down here and
this this is where we see the most
advantage and across the episodes this
is kind of the difference that we get in
terms of the navigation success rate yes
episodes yeah Levi was on the order of
hundred thousand I'll double check and
make sure that yeah that's what I
remember oh yeah
right we tried with them without so
imitation you can do by generating some
shortest paths in advance and then
learning to follow those and this isn't
a fine thing to do for pre training at
least in our experience at least in the
settings were looking at here and for
some exploration things it was it was
similar with him without yep but just as
your I think's getting at you know in
the in the absence of ample ample
experience in training this could
probably shorten the training time at
least yeah yep so this was good now this
good I mean we do hope that once we add
more sensing we get better at doing the
tasks and this happened you can see it
in the success rates but even more
exciting I think is this result where we
want to know you know can we remove this
GPS altogether for one thing it's a
sensor we can't truly rely on and it's
on perhaps unrealistic to say you enter
this new environment and there's already
a pointer telling you where the goal is
this isn't really so much matched to a
real-world task whereas entering a new
environment saying
where's that phone ringing I think is
and what this result shows is if we go
from on the left to having perfect GPS
to on the right to having more and more
corrupted GPS for all the agents hours
here shown in red and blue and that
baseline one this kind of status quo
which is in green what happens and so
that point goal agent that was so
strongly relying on dense GPS starts to
fail as that GPS signal is wrong the
audio goal agent which is one I'm just
introducing now this is an agent where
we don't even touch GPS and so it's
purely relying on visual and audio
streams and yet of course it's stable
now as the GPS gets wrong because we're
not looking at it this is good and
furthermore if you bring them together
the agent I talked about a second ago
both the audio and the GPS it's going to
degrade more gracefully because audio is
a proxy in some sense for that GPS
signal right it itself the audio we're
hearing is a pointer to the goal but we
would argue it's a more real-world
pointer to that goal so this is exciting
saying that you know in this setting
audio can start to supplant GPS and at
least let us have agents that can
navigate to audio sources without
relying on perfect GPS okay so in the
remainder I'm going to talk about
affordance learning we're on this will
round out this our current view of
learning representations and policies
from first-person point of from the
first-person point of view
I'll pause for a second because I'm
about to move out of the audio yes
please can you ablate the vision to in
the in that model so like if I just
follow the audio signal like that if I
follow the gradient of it the not
sufficient so I don't need to know
anything about the room yeah it wasn't
in that chart but we do have this tested
for the blind agent right where you
remove the visual at all and it's
inferior so the we still need the visual
and we still do better if we have it and
its effects like the one I was
mentioning like if you have a big
obstacle you know and but the audio in
this open room and I don't see anything
but I hear was down over there I go but
then I run into
the couch and so the visuals still plays
a role yeah and it kind of goes in that
order and our results consistent with
what others report you know depth
strongest RGB and then the blind yeah so
if you could move in three it up and
down you could maybe also result so I'm
thinking yeah like if I could like duck
behind something and I yeah I would hear
the audio change yeah so therefore I
would know there was an obstacle there
so I'm you could kind of make this even
richer and the baby yeah definitely and
I think you know there's nothing
stopping from pre computing those or
even event you know as we're working on
render them on the fly but you're right
we rendered the sound assuming an agent
like say a wheeled robot that's a
certain height and it's not able to dock
or fly but yes you you just want to
change that y-coordinate and then you
could receive the sound differently that
way and it would be fun to try yeah
alright so let me talk about interaction
and this is where I said earlier we care
about not just naming objects of a
thousand types in the world but looking
at the world to say how do I use the
objects that are there which objects can
I even use or how would I use them and
this is the notion of object affordances
meaning the potential for action so an
agent looking at this lamp would say
it's a lamp but also I can see that here
I could toggle something this looks
adjustable over here I could move the
base I could replace this part and I'm
well aware that a robot replacing a
light bulb sounds like a little
futuristic but we'll just go with this
example for the moment because of the
difficulties of the manipulation okay
but we want to see these objects in
terms of what we could do with them and
how do you do it now so current methods
have been looking at this really in a
standard supervised way where you say
okay we've got visual inputs like this
book and I want my system to predict
regions where a verb is possible like
where could I hold this book and so
people have trained things much in the
spirit of what's known as semantic
segmentation so usually used for objects
labeling but you can think of using it
for verb labeling to where people
crowdsource labels to say where I could
do these things and now you train models
that knew how to look at a new instance
and make similar labels okay like 2d
segmentation
so here's a problem though there's a
usual concern like it's heavily
supervised that's expensive but also
there's this hop of information right
where I'm asking you annotate or if I do
this approach we're asking annotators to
think about how would you hold this book
and then write it down with a mouse to
tell the system how to learn how to hold
a book and this is a hop that I think we
can avoid so our idea is to learn from
video how people use objects okay so
look at all the multiple ways you can
hold use a book here I'm showing you
from a few third-person views as well as
on the bottom right from a egocentric
first-person view we want to capture
these kind of interactions directly from
the video without this intermediator
intermediary of a person labeling images
so this is the problem we wanted we
wanted to address so let me show you how
this works so we consider it weekly
label data so we have video where no
one's said this is where you hold or
press or rotate the book but we have
video that is labeled for actions so we
have videos of people holding videos of
people opening and so on and those are
labeled in time so first thing we do is
train an action classifier with this
data so a stream of frames comes in this
is a LST I'm a sequential model and the
frames of the video that will then learn
how to aggregate this info overtime to
predict the right labels for a new video
a number of labels these verbs there
might be in the data sets I'll show you
there's like 20 to 125 of these verbs
that exists okay so that's just action
recognition so then what the new part
that we're doing here is then to think
let's train a model that knows how to
look at the object at rest the object
before anyone's interacting with it and
anticipate that this action could be
possible because that's what an
affordance is it's not saying well here
you're opening the book it's saying this
is where you could open the book or the
microwave so what we do is introduce a
module in this entire network that looks
at the object at rest and can anticipate
how the state of the aggregated state of
this temporal model for action would
look so what's the we learned the
mapping that map's this guy to this guy
and this guy is the ink aggregated state
of this sequential model
so that's key kind of this anticipation
of module that knows how to look at
things at rest and anticipate what what
actions are possible could be recognized
and now the final step then is how do
you turn that into spatially localized
information for the agent and for this
we take that same network and now look
back at with an activation maximization
kind of approach to find the spatial
regions in this photo that are most
responsible for the action decision for
any one of those verbs for example
pushing back through here to say okay
for this inactive object these are
regions that most allow my joint
anticipation recognition model to
anticipate the verb pulley ball or
simile I could do the same thing for the
verb pressable and I'll come back with a
different heat map for where it looks
like we could press this object okay
you'll have a whole stack of these maps
one map per each verb and again there's
maybe dozens 200 plus of these verbs in
the kind of video we look at and the key
thing to know here is that we're
learning this again not from people
drawing maps not from people even can
even doing contact recognition but from
watching egocentric or third-person
video ok so let me show you some of the
results two data sets the one on the
left is consisting of YouTube videos of
people demonstrating products so they
pull out the product they talk about it
they show you how to use it and coupled
with those videos you have product
images of the object at rest this is an
Oprah data set collected at Stanford the
one on the right is a recent large
egocentric data set called epic consists
of 32 people doing unscripted activities
in their kitchens 30 minutes at a time
ish and for about 55 hours of total
video and very natural kind of everyday
activity in the kitchen so again
remember then our goal is to be able to
take objects at rest
so we'll have views from either of these
data sets where no one's touching the
object and anticipate what kind of
manipulation is possible and where
furthermore we test this even for unseen
categories so
we wanted to be the case that you could
learn about open ability from cabinet
doors and then anticipate open ability
on the dishwasher door all right so it's
a visual thing that will translate
there's no boundaries on the objects
it's the boundaries are on the verbs all
right so first I'm gonna just show you
some pictures of what it looks like so
these are frame by frame estimates by
our method for the affordances that we
see and I'm showing here a color-coded
the top five most frequent ones that
happen in this epoch data set and you
could see in this example I'll go back
green means mixable so right before you
start mixing this looks like a visual
region that's mixable the person does
end up mixing this one and then over
here there's another one over here that
looks mixable we're anticipating that
this one the pink means washable so
there's some washable stuff that you're
actually washing don't forget this guy
over here this at rest object that also
looks washable this one that knife
dotted one this one yes not yet but they
should right it's detecting affordance
oh right so this isn't a model to
predict what you will do or this person
will do but it is predicting what this
object would afford whether you want to
do it next or not yes yes conditioned on
the fact that there's a sink nearby yeah
probably because it's looking at the
whole visual frame right exactly yeah if
I if I shifted if I had a bunch of dirty
plates that were just in Iraq I made
this like a little bit off frame like it
would it would presumably not mark them
as well as depending what was in the
training data yeah so like if if it was
learning about washable stuff in video
where you keep stuff like that yes and
then the more you keep it by the sink
exactly yeah and you'll notice it
happens to that it's it's not wanting to
watch these things even though there's
stuff sitting near the sink yeah now if
I I have to say you know it's not that
fine grain it's not that perfect if I
went into this video and put a knife
that was having no fragments of
food on it I mean it might also look
washable right so that's probably not
that fine-grain yet show you a couple
more here you know this looks mixable
there's nothing to mix those jars looked
open of all this door looks open abble
which is cool like I said we're learning
about doors or they're open ability
properties independent of the specific
category the last one I'll show on the
left this is salience II so off the
shelf sanity you get interesting regions
but they're not coded for action what
we're giving you is the in this method
is the ability to look at the video from
the first-person view of an agent
eventually a robot who knows what kind
of things are possible you know mix kind
of mixes I could open this from its
first-person point of view think about
how you could take a robotic arm which
is different than a hand and the whole
map transforms yeah through a transfer
learning procedure yeah starting with
static correct and looking like a
because you know go to a robot army
might have way different map of what you
can do without yeah that's right yeah
yeah so we know that our bodies are
different than robot bodies at the same
time this is giving us a way to put a
prior on wears you know we're in the
scene or even we're on the object are
things possible and actually if we hold
the thought on the robot I'll have one
slide two slides from now because we're
starting to get there with with a
simulated robot arm yeah but you know
for handling that domain shift you might
think about learning explicitly the
transfer between the two so we've
evaluated what I just showed you
quantitatively where you want to know
are those heat maps the correct heat
maps we can do that with some ground
truths that humans made we can do that
comparing to other ways you could weekly
supervised using gays or other saliency
as well as heavily supervised methods
and overall this is just to say that
across these two data sets across an
array of metrics looking at that heat
map correctness things are pretty good
they're certainly much better than the
existing methods that also have weak
forms of supervision and even starting
to compete with those that have very
heavy supervision yes okay I was
thinking about kind sources before the
whole washable problem
in this way I just have a segmentation
model and then 'wait a recognized knife
and then yeah I put you find us knife is
watchable other things are not washable
others I just saw it this way right yeah
that's a lot like this map this bassline
actually which is heavily supervised
because I think a shortcut you just
suggest it would be well I don't I at
least if I know this mapping between
object names and verbs I could say it
that way as opposed to drawing them but
the drawing them version of it that's
what the image to heat map baseline is
doing so heavy annotation you still had
to annotate the objects yeah for kind of
objects we combination or segmentation
cuz there's plenty of so I can and use
them yeah so I do not you I know takes
this it's a shortcut as saying like they
already annotated cocoa so like I'll use
those labels and then try to do
affordance yeah it would be a variation
on that one I think the cost still
exists as in someone did annotate that
data strongly super best solution is no
better than this we can express a
solution for this yes for this
evaluation metric of saying are the heat
maps correct against human written
ground truth and we we have to keep in
mind that we present that cuz it's very
firm about like how well is it doing but
as I said at the beginning there's also
this hop of like where humans say they
would do stuff versus how they do it
which might be a bit more diverse than
what we say with our mouse yeah question
do you think can we not use the object
labels at all and basically that this
replace all the object the teachers that
people are using those expensive labels
rain for base per minute well I mean
there's no object detection happening
here but but it's not gonna detect
objects it'll detect affordances so it
might be a hint about object boundaries
and things then does that still relying
on all the labels for the actions that
yes having this basis that's right ours
is using those action labels those are
the labels we use yep that's right could
we get rid of those maybe but the Viets
supervision is basically coming from the
fact that you don't have the labels for
the objects you want
have the Legos for the actions yeah
that's right yeah exactly
would insist transfer between the
innocents hmm the verbs from like Oprah
epic vice versa yeah I don't know their
overlap offhand I think some would some
would certainly overlap cuz then you you
want to test the one on the other maybe
right we haven't tried it what we did
try is to partition object categories to
say make sure the test set has unseen
not just instances but categories but we
haven't talked to the cross data set
it's a good thing to consider here is
that you have many less actions that map
to many more objects potentially much
less labeling but that's one advantage
oh yeah I think so and right I mean
that's why yeah this is these are
supervising different weak ways which is
kind of complex but the right labeling
labeling these videos for temporarily
for verbs is still a human label
although potentially more unambiguous
than asking people to label where do you
hold the spatula and I think to both
your questions I think you know I think
we could take this towards not needing
those action labels which would be nice
so that you don't have to commit to you
know it kind of language is kind of
perhaps even interfering here about what
we say we could perhaps discover these
actions from the video yes yes so
there's what she's like you're getting a
strong signal because of some action
happening at a particular pixel location
that you're that labeling afterwards
what happens when there's more
interaction a distance thinking like
doors are all open automatically when
you come close to them yeah and you
might want to label you know where would
I walk through right right the video
doesn't show the person interacting with
the door what does the door opens out
they approach right or if like a fan is
blowing air right and it's doing
something to an object at a distance or
something right with that with this
witness that's to work here or or yeah
yeah I mean I don't have a partition
numbers to say like how is it harder or
easier
but but the method yeah this is okay now
as in what you're learning from the
video is what to look for and so it's
not saying you have to see the hands or
the contact yes so those kind of things
would be okay
it's not shown here but we did have a
baseline that's based on hand detection
which makes a lot of sense it's actually
non-trivial to detect the hands with ego
video and furthermore the field of view
of these cameras will affect how often
you even see the hands we found when we
do our own ego video collection like
eating a lot of food never makes it into
the video because you can you can eat
like this you don't have to like take
your GoPro and look down at the food so
the field of view actually will limit
how much you even see the body in the
view yeah but the opening doors yeah
it's a fun one to think about I think
the model is consistent with
understanding actions like that so I
want to show you two more results two
slides and then we'll close and they're
both still with this interaction
hotspots and I'll show you a bit where
we're going with it now that we have
this tool maybe tools like it that we
can develop further one is I'd like to
see how understanding how objects work
or what functions are afforded will
actually help us recognize them you and
I do this think about yourself at your
friends kitchen you know they have this
new looking tool in the drawer but
you're like oh you know I could use this
like a spatula I think it's a spatula
right you haven't seen that one before
it's a little bit different but that's
fine you understand the function it's
recognizable I'd like to translate that
ability to these systems so we've
started trying this and we have some
kind of initial results where we try to
encode the objects the normal way to do
object recognition here on cocoa objects
and we encode them with these
interaction hotspots as well as their
appearance so what I'm showing you here
is that if you have a refrigerator that
looks like a canonical refrigerator
everything's just great and as you move
more towards these unusual views or
contacts then and off the shelf ResNet
model trying to do object recognition
will start to be unsure totally makes
sense the visual pattern is just not as
consistent but if we code these kinds of
images both again both as that resident
encoding that was learned for these
tasks as well as these verbs in here I'm
just showing two of them like holdable
open a bowl so not the
Maps themselves but the features coming
from this model we can actually start to
see some improvement to recognition so
there's no greater supervision side from
you know we've learned these interaction
hotspots but now we take a low shot
version of this task so as low as five
training examples per class and that's
where we see the benefit of having this
interaction learning from video to do
now object recognition if you go all the
way to non low shot if you use all the
training data that advantage goes away
okay so it's most valuable right now if
you just haven't seen a lot of these
training instances which makes sense
okay so by anticipating object function
we can get better low shot object
recognition and finally back to Eric's
suggestion we're starting to look at how
to translate this to the robot and we're
going there through a simulator first so
the idea is this if we've learned the
about these hot spots how to touch
objects where to touch them how to
interact with them now an agent that's
learning a policy for how to do those
actions or first here how to just do
grasping of a new object can use that
human exhibited intelligence of how to
interact with objects to do it better to
learn it faster so here we're taking a
this 24 degree of freedom dexterous hand
simulator we're rewarding here in the
baseline nothing other than getting that
thing off of the table and staying
getting close to the center of mass so
here this kind of in this instance if
you do the baseline you know it's in
this case it's failing to learn here try
and learn from scratch how to pick up
this object okay and it's hard but now
if you do this training while having
that hot spot kind of model something to
tell you where people would start to
interact with the object this prior
helps it learn it successfully and
actually learn it faster so what you're
seeing is this for this very same object
it's learned ways to pick it up and the
thing that you're seeing that's us
testing the stability of the grasp we're
pushing that robot arm around to see if
it you know our hypothesis is that not
only will you succeed at picking it up
but you won't pick it up in some crazy
way that just happened to work for a
moment you'll pick it up away like a
human would that might be more stable
okay so this is all totally ongoing but
we're starting to bring the
- together yes the control primitives
are using in this uh yeah individual
joint torques or higher on wall yeah all
of the joints for the hand yeah and the
position of the wrists again yeah and
the uniform center of maths or like mass
distribution inside of the objects or it
brings us with these thing that handles
is that is the you haven't waited such
that the like the pan is heavier than
the handle this
oh good question what do what kind of
mass is in the mesh itself for the
objects we haven't altered it so it
would you know so believe this mean in
the simulator be uniform yeah did you
have more to say about don't know just
curat that's really the easy right thing
to do for start I was just kidding I
just probably be hard if you I'm
specifically think of the pan case yeah
like it makes sense that it'd be easy
for the agent to learn you can pick it
up from almost any lip normally but the
handles gonna be particularly right
convenient for a hammer on the other
hand if the weight distribution is
really far away then there's gonna be
this kind of leer yeah
it's work to it yes yes yeah we could
think of how to take these models so
these models were from contact DB from
Georgia Tech and we're looking at the
ycb objects as well and I don't know
what kind of waiting they provide in
those honestly yet but yeah they're just
the measures there's no yeah yeah so it
doesn't like somebody think about in
this case when you're providing the
videos as well would put something
directly doing imitation based transfer
be irrelevant base you think about it
would but but I'd like to see this
succeed without imitation being required
like so if we don't have humans
demonstrating with gloves you know how
to do this match to this simulator but
we do have what we have now which is ego
video kind of off-the-shelf real world
in the wild by the way we haven't
totally these this is preliminary and we
haven't totally done this gotten there
with in the wild video I think that's a
strength if we can do that right so
certainly yeah I make
total sense another avenue to approach
this problem is saying I've got people
that can come in the lab and they can
show you how to take a glove and do it
but can we learn this from scratch plus
video that's the main novelty could you
not generate synthetic data I was
trading data for this kind of task
instead of having to get actual
synthetic meaning what being done use
graphics to generate different scenarios
because you control that yeah yeah well
I mean if I understand your question
right that is what's happening here and
that you can control this the robot arm
and you also get these RGB frames
rendered from which to learn about the
experience of trying to grasp failing
not failing you don't want to bring
people into jewel yeah well here both
the baseline @nr method would be
learning from the frames that get
rendered in simulation the part we were
talking about over there is where if you
actually need a human demonstrator to do
it and yet neither of these is requiring
that neither the baseline or that one
these robotic rooms are not limited to
what we can do like a robot doesn't care
if it's holding a metal pot that's
boiling yeah because if it's got
materials that can withstand up great
doesn't that look constraint yeah yeah
it also has suction capabilities doesn't
mean by manipulation always yeah it's
simply a suction that's true yeah yeah
like this human bias from video is only
gonna go to a certain point and it's
totally totally agreed both for
embodiment and sensing capabilities
safety all of these things but what it
will do we think is allow look at the
object probably especially in terms of
its shape and know where to approach it
yeah so in this particular case just to
understand the input to the system is an
image and your hot spots that's it yeah
so I'm kind of giving you the preview of
where we're at currently not all these
wires are connected so in this case
we're taking you know based on uses
center of mass over here we're using
we're actually using human data about
from from the Georgia Tech data about
the contact would happen but the idea is
to then this point that we're targeting
over here will be the hot spots learn
from the video right I think I concerned
like what we'll have to overcome to get
that is that take those epic videos
which are so cluttered and you know
real-world to a clean visual like this
it's not it's it's to be determined how
bad that is
right how big about if not them so
Kristen will be at the further room to
answer your one-on-one says I think very
much
[Applause]